I'm finding that on one of my longer nights of my life treatment, I have to interrupt my last hour.
So I assume you're waking up and you're like, oh, I'm going to get up and get going here,
and there's still an hour left in my program. What is the acceptable amount of time to put
on pause before returning back to it? I mean, if you are getting up on one of the nights and
pausing it and coming back to it, there's no harm in doing that no matter what the time is.
But do you have to? No, you don't have to. Remember, there's frequencies in it that are
constantly recycling. That's how I write the programs because you really shouldn't be
running frequencies more than three minutes, 180 seconds at any given time with some exceptions.
You go up to six minutes or so, but you so they have to recycle. So you add up how many
frequencies can you run in an eight hour program or running several hundred frequencies, but even
several hundred frequencies, they're recycling. Otherwise, we would only have a four hour program.
So you're getting those again. So if you are, if somebody's got, let's say, eight and a half hour
programs and they ask me, well, I only literally, only sleep five and a half hours every day. I have to go
to I, you know, I've had a trucker that did that. He has to go to work. He's only weeks, five and a half
hours. So and I shortened his program. But by all means, if you're if you're missing an hour or
an hour and a half, every, every couple, every few days or a few of the programs and you know,
that's fine. So you're you're doing fine. And if you are pausing it, coming back to it,
then you're not missing anything. So